[Music]
they're only 17 and 19 years old but
they've already established their own
firms these teenagers are also pretty
good at selling themselves my team
developed the app skills for school
we've developed the data glove it allows
you to study on the go we want to
revolutionize physiotherapy and make it
more efficient Reuben Lindh launched his
company four weeks ago rather than going
to class he's filming a video to
motivate other teenagers to become
entrepreneurs the last few months
weren't quite as entertaining he had to
make frequent trips to the district
court to reassure worried officials I
try not to show it but all the red tape
you face if you're a miner wanting to
set up a business is annoying the
bureaucracy is daunting he's not allowed
to sign contracts but he was able to
program an app allowing students to
access their textbooks via a smartphone
and he also learned how to set up a
business on the internet not in school
we set up a company that exists on paper
only just to see what kind of legal form
makes sense to what extent am i
personally liable what can I actually
set up you don't learn that kind of
thing in school these two 19 year olds
are also learning how to run a business
rather than the proper bedroom
engineering student Garrett Zimmerman
has a workshop his rehabilitation glove
is connected to a virtual reality
headset it allows you to train your hand
with video games he was 15 when he came
up with that idea it's left him with no
time to study
lands on the system this kind of project
occupies you 24/7 you're constantly
thinking about how you can correct
mistakes how can I improve efficiency he
won a spot in a startup incubator with
15000 euros of capital business lessons
and one-on-one coaching the technology
is in place and investors are interested
but it's hard to gain a foothold in the
market for example he's encountered
problems due to his age at trade fairs
after a presentation for example a
professor might be very interested in
the project and asked at the outset who
is behind it and then it comes out that
I myself and the developer a small Dutch
consultancy could help the healthcare
sector is relatively conservative
insurance companies and patient
associations a risk-averse
care not and his three colleagues who
are all the same age have been advised
to look for partners with more
experience the power of being young is
that you look thinking opportunities and
you're very enthusiastic passionate
about your own innovation and you need
some people that ask you'd the critical
questions and to prevent you forum have
step into pitfalls Rubin Lind has
arranged a meeting with a representative
of corneas and publishing house since he
doesn't have an office a cafe has to do
the young entrepreneur wants the school
textbook publishers to provide content
for his app he thinks they need to
adjust more to the needs of digital
natives
we don't run around the whole time
carrying our books but we do have our
smartphones why do I have to drag around
a book in my bag when I can buff up for
the next exam on my smartphone next
summer
Ruben's going to take his school leaving
exams University can wait first he wants
to focus his energies on his startup